comme Pong, Snake et Tetris.
Vous imaginez l'immense joie de jouer
à un jeu Tetris que vous avez codé vous-même en JACK
et compilé en langage informatique dans un compilateur
que vous avez aussi codé vous-même, et voir ce résultat
qui fonctionne sur une machine que vous avez construite
à partir de rien de plus que quelques milliers de fonctions NAND.
C'est un exploit personnel fantastique que de partir des
principes de base et d'aller jusqu'à un système
extrêmement complexe et utile.
Noam et moi avons travaillé pendant cinq ans pour faciliter
ce cheminement et créer les outils et les infrastructures
qui aideront les élèves à le construire en un semestre.
Et voici la fantastique équipe qui nous a aidés à réaliser tout ça
L'astuce était de scinder la construction de l'ordinateur
en plusieurs modules autonomes,
dont chacun pourrait être spécifié individuellement,
construit et testé seul, isolé du reste du projet.
Et dès le premier jour, Noam et moi avons décidé de placer
tous ces documents d'aide à la construction gratuitement
en open source sur Internet.
Les spécifications des puces, les API, les descriptions de projet,
les outils informatiques, les simulateurs hardware, les émulateurs d'unité centrale,
des piles de centaines de slides de cours --
nous avons tout mis en ligne
et nous avons invité le monde entier à venir,
prendre tout ce dont ils avaient besoin,
et faire ce qu'ils voulaient avec.
Et alors quelque chose de fascinant est arrivé.
Le monde est venu.
Et très vite, des milliers de gens
se mettaient à construire notre machine.
Et NAND2Tetris est devenu l'un des premiers tutoriels
de grande ampleur, ouvert et en ligne,
bien que sept ans plus tôt, nous n'avions aucune idée que
ce que nous faisions est appelé MOOC (cours en ligne ouverts et massifs).
Nous avons juste observé que des cours auto-organisés
se frayaient spontanément un chemin
à partir de nos documents pédagogiques.
Par exemple, Pramode C.E.,
un ingénieur de Kerala en Inde,
a réuni un groupe d'autodidactes
qui construisent notre ordinateur avec son aide.
Et Parag Shah, un autre ingénieur de Bombay,
a scindé nos projets en d'encore plus petits
fragments, plus gérables, qu'il propose désormais
dans son très novateur programme informatique qui consiste à apprendre par la pratique.
Les gens qui sont attirés par ces cours
ont typiquement un profil de hacker.
Ils veulent comprendre comment les choses fonctionnent,
et ils veulent le faire en groupe,
comme ces clubs de hackers à Washington D.C.,
qui utilisent nos documents pour des cours communautaires.
Et parce que ces supports sont largement disponibles
et en open source, des gens très différents les utilisent
pour raisons très différentes et imprévisibles.
Par example, Yu Fangmin, de Guangzhou,
a utilisé la technologie d'un réseau de portes programmables (FPGA)
pour construire notre ordinateur et montrer aux autres comment faire de même
en utilisant une vidéo, et Ben Craddock a développé
un superbe jeu vidéo qui vous plonge
à l'intérieur de notre architecture CPU, qui est un dédale 3D
très complexe que Ben a développé
en utilisant le moteur de simulation 3D de Minecraft.
La communauté Minecraft est devenue complètement dingue de ce projet,
et Ben est instantanément devenu une célébrité médiatique.
En en effet, pour pas mal de personnes,
faire ce "pèlerinage" NAND2Tetris, si vous voulez,
s'est transformé en une expérience qui a changé leur vie.
Par exemple, Dan Rounds, qui étudie la musique et
les mathématiques à East Lansing, dans le Michigan.
Il y a quelques semaines, Dan a posté un message de victoire
sur notre site et j'aimerais vous le lire.
Voici ce que Dan a dit.
"J'ai suivi le cours en ligne parce que comprendre les ordinateurs
est important pour moi, tout comme les compétences en lecture et en calcul,
et j'ai réussi. Je n'ai jamais travaillé aussi dur,
je n'ai jamais été autant mis à l'épreuve.
Mais étant donné ce dont je me sens capable désormais,
je le referais certainement.
A ceux qui envisagent de se lancer avec NAND2Tetris,
c'est un parcours difficile mais vous en ressortirez profondément changés."
Dan décrit les nombreux autodidactes
qui prennent ce cours en ligne, de leur propre volonté,
de leur propre initiative et c'est vraiment étonnant car
ces gens ne se préoccupent absolument pas
des notes.
Ils le font uniquement par motivation personnelle.
Ils ont une incroyable passion pour apprendre.
Et en gardant ça à l'esprit,
j'aimerais dire quelques mots à propos du système de notation traditionnel des universités.
Il me rend malade.
Nous sommes obsédés par les notes
parce que nous sommes obsédés par les données,
et donner une note ôte tout l'aspect positif de l'échec,
et pourtant une grande partie de l'éducation
est liée à l'échec.
D'après Churchill, le courage
est la capacité d'aller d'une défaite à une autre
sans perdre de son enthousiasme. (Rires)
Et [Joyce] a dit que les erreurs
sont les portails de la découverte.
Et pourtant, nous ne tolérons pas les erreurs,
et nous vénérons les notes.
Alors nous collectons vos bonnes notes
et nous les agrégeons toutes en un seul nombre, par exemple 13,
qui est tamponné sur votre front
et définit qui vous êtes.
A mon avis, nous sommes allés bien trop loin avec cette absurdité,
et donner des notes est devenu dégradant.
Donc j'aimerais dire quelques mots sur l'amélioration,
et partager avec vous un aperçu de mon projet actuel,
qui est différent du précédent,
mais en partage exactement les mêmes caractéristiques
d'auto-apprentissage, d'apprentissage par la pratique,
d'auto-exploration et de conscience communautaire,
et ce projet traite de la formation en mathématiques jusqu'au niveau lycée,
en débutant avec les maths pour les jeunes enfants,
et nous le faisons sur des tablettes car nous pensons que
les maths, comme tout le reste, devraient être enseignées par la pratique.
Ce que nous faisons: en gros, nous avons développé
de nombreuses applications mobiles, chacune d'elles expliquant
un concept particulier des mathématiques.
Par exemple, prenons l'aire.
Quand on a affaire à un concept tel que l'aire --
nous fournissons aussi un ensemble d'outils que l'enfant
est invité à essayer, utiliser, explorer pour apprendre.
Et donc si on s'intéresse à l'aire,
une chose facile à faire est de morceler l'aire
de cette forme et de simplement compter
combien de morceaux il faut pour la couvrir entièrement.
Et ce petit exercice vous donne un premier
véritable aperçu de la notion d'aire.
Continuons, qu'en est-il de l'aire de cette figure ?
Si l'on essaie de la morceler, ça ne marche pas très bien.
Alors à la place, on peut faire des essais
avec les différents outils sur la tablette en suivant
un processus guidé d'apprentissage par expérimentation,
et à un moment donné vous découvrirez qu'une des choses
que vous pouvez faire parmi de nombreuses transformations justifiées
est la suivante. Vous pouvez couper la figure,
vous pouvez réarranger les morceaux, vous pouvez les recoller
et ensuite procéder au morcellement exactement comme nous l'avions fait auparavant.
(Applaudissements)
Alors, cette transformation en particulier
n'a pas changé l'aire de la figure originale,
et donc un enfant de six ans qui joue avec ça
vient de découvrir un algorithme très intelligent
servant à calculer l'aire de n'importe quel parallélogramme.
Au fait, nous ne remplaçons pas les enseignants.
Nous croyons que les enseignants devraient gagner en pouvoir, non pas être remplacés.
Continuons, que pouvons-nous dire de l'aire d'un triangle ?
Après un peu d'apprentissage guidé par expérimentation,
l'enfant va découvrir, avec ou sans aide,
qu'il ou elle peut dupliquer la figure initiale,
puis prendre le résultat, le transposer,
le recoller sur l'original et ensuite refaire ce que nous avons fait auparavant:
couper, réarranger, coller - oups - coller,
et morceler.
Cette transformation a doublé l'aire
de la figure originelle, et donc nous venons d'apprendre
que l'aire du triangle équivaut à celle de ce rectangle
divisée par deux.
Mais nous l'avons découvert par auto-exploration.
Ainsi, en plus d'apprendre des principes utiles de géométrie,
l'enfant a été exposé à des stratégies scientifiques
plutôt sophistiquées, comme la réduction,
qui est l'art de
transformer un problème complexe en un problème simple,
ou la généralisation, qui est au coeur
de toute discipline scientifique,
ou encore le fait que quelques propriétés sont invariantes
sous certaines transformations.
Et tout ceci est quelque chose qu'un jeune enfant
peut comprendre en utilisant de telles applications mobiles.
Actuellement, nous faisons les choses suivantes:
D'abord, nous décomposons le programme de math jusqu'au niveau lycée
en de nombreuses applications comme celle-ci.
Et comme nous ne pouvons le faire tout seuls,
nous avons développé un très bel outil de création
que n'importe quel auteur, n'importe quel parent, ou même quiconque
intéressé par l'enseignement des mathématiques,
puisse utiliser cet outil de création pour développer des applications similaires
sur des tablettes sans devoir programmer.
Et finalement, nous mettons en place un écosystème adaptatif
qui s'harmonise aux différents apprenants
avec différentes applications adaptées à l'évolution de leur style d'apprentissage.
La force motrice derrière ce projet
est mon collègue Shmulik London,
et vous voyez, exactement comme
Salman l'a fait il y a environ 90 ans,
l'astuce est de s'entourer de gens brillants,
parce qu'au final,
tout ce qui compte, ce sont les gens.
Il y a quelques années, je marchais dans Tel Aviv,
et j'ai vu ce graffiti sur un mur,
et je l'ai trouvé tellement envoûtant,
que désormais je le fais découvrir à mes élèves,
et j'aimerais vous le faire découvrir.
Je ne sais pas combien de personnes ici connaissent
le terme "mensch".
Il signifie simplement être humain
et agir correctement.
Et ce que ce graffiti dit, c'est
"High-tech, schmigh tech.
Le plus important c'est d'être un mensch." (Rires)
Merci. (Applaudissements)
(Applaudissements)